hey guys in this video I'm going to talk about
leaky gut IBS Crohn's and vitamin deficiency
what happens is that a lot of people get damaged
in their intestines from antibiotics from viruses
from certain microbes and the little tiny hairs or
cilia or roots in your intestine become damaged to
the point where you don't absorb like you did
anymore so like in a little plant that has the
roots your intestines are the roots just like
a plant that absorb the nutrients so one of the
biggest things that doesn't go in is it something
called bile B I le that's like the detergent that
helps dissolve grease and pull it pulls in fat
soluble vitamins so if you're consuming food and
the bile gets released and it doesn't get absorbed
in the small intestine but later down in the chain
of intestines because you have like 33 feet of
intestines so let's say it finally gets absorbed
way down there that can be the wrong place to
be absorbed and it can create a problem like
an excessive laxative in that you have diarrhea
bloating cramping because the bile can even act
as a toxic thing and normally you would absorb
reabsorb about 95% of all your bile okay and it
goes right back to the liver to the lymphatics
and then it recycles well with these conditions
you will be losing all your bio so it's going to
be point where you have too much bile and then you
don't hardly have any at all so you can fluctuate
between constipation and diarrhea all the time so
there's a couple things that you need to know
about not having bile number one that's when
you start having vitamin deficiencies so all the
vitamin deficiencies of vitamin A would be vision
problems at night skin problems sinus issues all
the inner skin like your immune system you're
going to have those despite consuming vitamin A
products because you don't have the bile because
the intestine is damaged this is just a this is a
big common cause of a lot of vitamin deficiencies
and then you have vitamin E that's good for the
art it's good for hormones it's good for skin
so all of a sudden you have all this dry skin
and you wondering where that came from then you
have vitamin D vitamin D helps the absorption
of calcium and magnesium by 20% in the small
intestine well if it's damaged if the lining of
your intestine is damaged you're not going to
pull in that vitamin D so right there there goes
the immune system there goes the calcium there
goes the minerals you can't pull these things in
and you can't sleep it leads it to a cascade of
issues so one of the remedies for the for these
conditions is high amounts of vitamin D if you
can absorb them then you have k1 and k2 those are
involved with clotting and k2 is involved with
the mobilization of calcium out of the arteries so
again if you can't absorb those those you can have
a lot of problems with the blood pressure heart
problems arthritis bursitis things like that okay
so that's another cause of vitamin deficiency
despite you eating them so here's what you have
to do you have to heal the intestinal wall so you
can have to avoid a couple things of course you're
gonna have to avoid the most obvious thing which
is gluten okay you have to avoid in fact avoid all
grains if you have Nicky got IBS or Crohn's and
you're still doing grains that is a huge problem
for you so I mean if we just eliminate grains
and even including gluten or not probably a lot
of your problems will clear right up dairy if
you have these issues going to have allergies
to dairy so just cut the dairy out you can't do
cheese you can't do milk so those two things are
the no-brainer of course also what comes with that
with the breads the pasta cereal crackers biscuits
all that and the sugar so if we eliminate that
that's good but there's things that you can do
bone broth is a really good healer because it's
loaded with the glutamine which is actually heals
the lining of the intestine you can take also a
good probiotic sometimes some of these probiotics
are too strong and they can create a war and
more of a detox so you might want to start off
slowly I like a microbe called effective microbes
and I'll put down below you can get it on Amazon
or another website but in fact microbes are a
nice blend of a lot of different microbes that
all work synergistically cabbage is one of the
vegetables that are it's really loaded without
glutamine and it's good for officers and you can
do cabbage juice that's a real good healer of the
intestines cabbage is good for heartburn you can
take it in many different forms you can cook it
steam it you can eat it raw but you may have a
problem with it raw so you might have to steam
it and that includes avoiding too many foods with
too many fibers too because fiber could irritate
and overwhelm the microbes so this whole thing
with you even doing a kale shake blended could
be a problem you might not be able to do that
because you don't have the microbes yet to be
able to pull it off pickle juice seems to be a
real safe thing good for the intestines anything
with lactic acid like kombucha tea would be good
episode of vinegar would be good for some people
ghee is clarified butter that's also good if
it's grass-fed that has some fat soluble vitamins
especially vitamin A because what we don't want
to do we don't want to avoid too many vital
vitamins because since you're deficient in these
nutrients you're going to have to consume them in
larger amounts for something to go in there I mean
we're not going to just avoid those nutrients so
we have to put them in somehow so then in green
juices that will provide chlorophyll to help heal
the inner skin the wheatgrass juice is the best
because it has a certain hormonal growth factor
in there that's really beneficial to damaged
skin and we all the inside of our intestines
are basically kind of a skin it's an inner skin
so that would be really good to clean and heal the
intestines okay so anyway so that's the summary
of that and if you have these conditions it could
be why you're deficient in these nutrients
all right thank you so much for watching